despite its recent resurgence in the pop
culture landscape superheroes and comic
books have been with us for over 80
years and just like its host of
larger-than-life characters the history
of comic books is chock-full of wild
stories there's sometimes more
entertaining than the heroes themselves
and also lets you see what others don't
like the irony of these two movie
adaptations opening only a month apart
though they might seem unrelated these
two heroes share a much longer history
if it wasn't for a single lawsuit it
might not have seen either of them at
all to tell this story we need to go
back to where it began and it starts
with one man that you will recognize in
an instant the arrival of Superman on
the comics scene was revolutionary his
1938 debut in Action Comics number one
essentially gave birth to the superhero
genre and what is now referred to as the
Golden Age of comics he was everywhere
in his own national radio program
newspaper comic strips and animated
short as well as a TV series it was
shared in virtually every possible
format imaginable except one movies
that's because someone else took his
place
Captain Marvel was another hero that
made his debut in Wis comics number two
in the late 1939 published by Fawcett
comics
it featured a 12 year old orphan news
boy named Billy Batson who can transform
into an adult superhero by shouting one
word
Captain Marvel became an instant success
launching his own new independent series
Captain Marvel adventures which would
later go on to sell more copies than
Superman in fact for a while Captain
Marvel was the most popular superhero of
the time so popular that it became the
first superhero ever to be adapted into
a motion picture now there's more story
behind us the studio behind the film
Republic Pictures was originally working
with DC or national comics publications
at the time to make a Superman picture
but they already had an existing cartoon
deal with Paramount Pictures which
prohibited them from signing another so
Republic Pictures chose Captain Marvel
instead DC was obviously not pleased
Fawcett had already published Master Man
an obvious copy of Superman but they
stopped publishing after DC had
threatened with lawsuit they believed
Captain Marvel was just another
imitation as well in June 1941 national
comics finally sued Fawcett for
copyright infringement
this began national Comics publications
vs. Fawcett publications one of the
longest-running legal battles in the
history of comic books lasting over two
whole fears here's what happened DC's
argument was simple that Captain
Marvel's main powers and characteristics
were too similar to Superman and
therefore infringed on its copyright
fosset argued that although these two
characters were similar it wasn't to the
point of infringement and that similar
feats have already been performed by
other fictional characters like Popeye
or Tarzan prove their point national
comics prepared a binder over 150 pages
in length with panels from their comics
of Superman juxtaposed with similar
panels of Captain Marvel everything was
in close scrutiny from their costumes
boots capes the ability to leap great
distances the ability to fly
extraordinary strength and speed
invincibility two bullet shells
explosives and their secret identity
they went as far as to include that they
both had clean-cut faces the verdict was
clear the judge eventually ruled that
Captain Marvel was indeed a copy of
Superman but it was Fawcett who won the
trial it was all because of one tiny
mistake a mistake that looked like this
this was the copyright symbol used back
in the 1950s the lawyers from Fawcett
discovered that McClure syndicate the
newspaper company that published the
Superman comics had forgotten to place
these symbols on several of their strips
and argued that DC had no copyright to
Superman and the court agreed this was
devastating news for DC it meant that it
did not own Superman and that anyone
could publish Superman stories without
legal repercussions this lasted over two
years out of 160 strips of Superman
published from January 1939
to April 1950 listen half of them or
from Detective Comics DC immediately
appealed and despite the damage the
decision was reversed the judge of the
case learned hand declared Captain
Marvel a deliberate and unabashed
duplicate of Superman and told Fawcett
to seize all of its publications and pay
DC for the damage it owes Fawcett
settled
by 1950 the Golden Age of comic books
had come to an end
sales were slumping to all-time lows and
Fawcett simply decided that it wasn't
worth fighting
they paid four hundred thousand dollars
in damages almost four million dollars
by today's standards and with its last
issue it seemed like the end for Captain
Marvel as you well know it was not a
brand new publication that no one knew
at the time trademarked the name after
it was abandoned by Fawcett that
publication was called marvel it took
repeating slumps in sales and six
different iterations until Carol Danvers
whom most of us are now familiar with
took on the mantle of Captain Marvel in
2012 meanwhile DC Comics looking for a
new hero to add to their lineup bought
the rights to all of Fawcett superheroes
in 1972 including the original Captain
Marvel the irony was that DC couldn't
call him Captain Marvel because Marvel
had the name and decided to name him
after the magic catchphrase that turns
him into a superhero and in 2019 these
two movies are being released just a
month apart from one another the
National Comics publications vs. Fawcett
publications is a prime example of the
thin line between plagiarism and
inspiration and the tricky balance that
all artists had to find in the early
years growing pain of sorts if it hadn't
been for Superman a revolution in pop
culture history we wouldn't have had to
Sam and if it hadn't been for Shazam we
would not have had Captain Marvel
ironically enough Superman as we know
might not have existed without Shazam as
well during the first few years Superman
also drew lots of inspiration from the
original Captain Marvel like how his
bald mad scientist arch-nemesis dr.
sivana
led to lex luthor as for superman having
the gift of flight it was Captain Marvel
who perform that feat first
a Superman who can't fly can you imagine
that neither can I
and that alone might be a good enough
reason why we need chat